Speaker 1: This you just have to see.
For more than a year now, the right has been
saying open everything, stop mask's open schools,
open restaurants to full capacity.
Look at all these left wing Doumar saying
clothes, everything forever.
Just open it up.
Now, of course, over time, if we started to
vaccinate people, we've started to open things.
But Joe Biden was going too slowly for them
or so they said.
He wasn't doing enough.
Biden keeps wearing his mask.
He's going to slowly vaccinated.
People don't need masks.
So last week, the CDC comes out and says,
hey, we have more information about how effective
these vaccines are.
And they are so effective that vaccinated
people don't really need masks outdoors, indoors,
but still pay attention to state rules and
pay attention to the businesses, the rules
of businesses that you're in.
Great Fox News and right wingers are thrilled.
Right?
Wrong.
Check out all the new complaints that these
bad faith actors came up with.
First, Fox News runs a very suspicious story,
pointing out that CDC chief moves from impending
doom to no masks for the vaccinated in 45
days.
On March 29th, Dr. Rochelle Walensky warned
the nation of dire days ahead.
And yet suddenly no more masks for vaccinated
people in many situations pending state guidelines.
That's suspicious, even though she did what
the Trumpet's have been asking for for a year,
even before it was safe to do it.
Totally bad faith.
Totally pathetic.
Here's another one.
After this announcement about masks from the
CDC, Joe Biden also made a statement updating
people on the new CDC guidance for masks.
Fox News interviews Republican Senator Shelley
Moore Capito from West Virginia.
And the story is, well, why didn't Joe Biden
thank Donald Trump?
Why didn't Joe Biden think operation warp
speed?
Why didn't Joe Biden thank Alex Azar?
Can you imagine?
I know it's laughable, but check this out.
Speaker 2: Were you struck by the fact that
the president did not make a single mention
of operation warp speed, whether it's Redfield
or Azar
Speaker 1: or Jarah or President Trump?
Speaker 2: None of that came yesterday.
How come?
Well, I mean, I'm always one that wants to
give credit where credit is is warranted and
certainly operation warp speed.
President Trump put all of this into motion
and President Biden has followed through on
it.
Speaker 1: So the news isn't look at the progress.
What great news, Joe Biden and the CDC liberating
people.
The story is Biden said it, but he didn't
think Trump and he didn't thank Robert Redfield
or Alex Azar or Operation Warp Speed.
And yet, if we're giving credit for putting
things in motion, where are these very people
about the January 6th riots that Donald Trump
put in motion?
They're very quiet there.
It really takes gumption to find something
bad about an announcement that they wanted
all along, that for the first time in over
a year, if you're vaccinated, if you followed
the CDC guidelines, you don't have to wear
masks.
If Joe Biden built a thousand miles of wall
on the southern border, Fox News would be
saying, can we afford this?
These immigrants are escaping drug cartels.
After all, this is too expensive.
If Joe Biden said guns for everyone, no background
checks.
You got it.
Republicans just have added Newsmax would
say, what if a kid hurt themselves?
Why doesn't Joe Biden care about kids?
They deserve none of our consideration as
serious participants in any discussion because
they aren't serious participants in any discussion